nos piden simplificar de que multiplica
a 4 de elevado a la potencia un medio
veamos que podemos hacer aquí hay muchos
caminos para hacer esto aquí revisaremos
todos de x 4 de algún medio 4 de alón
medio enfoquémonos en esto 4 de alá un
medio si tomas el producto de dos
factores y lo elevas a un exponente es
lo mismo que elevar cada uno de los
factores al exponente y después realizar
el producto así es que 4 de alón medio
lo puedes escribir como 4 elevado a un
medio por de elevado al un medio y por
supuesto eso multiplicado por de podría
poner un paréntesis aquí pero no importa
porque estoy tomando el producto de
estos tres términos así es que ponemos
esa de adelante y aquí tenemos dos
maneras de hacer esto elevamos cuatro la
potencia un medio con lo cual sacamos su
raíz cuadrada principal es decir su raíz
cuadrada positiva así es que esto va a
ser 4 elevado a la potencia un medio es
igual a 2 podemos poner ahora esta de
después del 2
a ponerla después del 2 y esto x de
elevado a la potencia en medio y aquí
hay varias maneras de representar esto
dependiendo de yo no sé cómo lo veas
digamos más estético podrías considerar
que esto es de elevado a la potencia 1 y
este sea la potencia un medio por lo
cual esto sería entonces 2 x de elevado
a la 1 más un medio que es un entero un
medio o de elevado a la tres medios así
es que este es una simplificación de la
expresión otra simplificación es
considerar que de elevado a un medio es
la raíz cuadrada de un medio
así es que esto también podría
escribirse como 2 por d por la raíz
cuadrada de de cualquiera de estas dos
son simplificaciones válidas lo que es
interesante aquí es considerar que ambas
representan lo mismo